TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi everyone
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Ariana Mott.
She is a software
engineer on Daydream.
Hi, Ariana.
ARIANA MOTT: Hi Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How
are you doing today?
ARIANA MOTT: I'm doing great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I mean, how
can you not be doing great?
We're in Florida and we're at
the Grace Hopper conference.
ARIANA MOTT: Yeah, it's been
super fun meeting tons of women
we're really interested in VR.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you gave
a presentation on Daydream--
ARIANA MOTT: Well--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: More about VR
development in general, right?
And things that developers
should consider, both sort
of technical and a
little less technical
about making a great
experience for people in VR.
And I don't think we have
the time or the slide deck
to get through all of them,
but I was hoping maybe you
could tell us, what's
something that you
didn't expect when you started
working on VR about building
an experience for people?
ARIANA MOTT: I think
something I didn't expect
was that there was no one to one
relationship of something that
will definitely work in VR--
whether that be technical,
in terms of how someone's
body will physically respond
to something, or
emotional comfort
or psychological comfort,
in terms of what people
are comfortable with in VR.
We talked about a lot
of the exploratory stuff
we've done to figure out
what types of things do work
and what kind of
things we should avoid.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I imagine
that there is a fair amount--
based on what you're saying--
of, we think this will work.
Let's try it.
ARIANA MOTT: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
You just, kind of,
have to get that
headset on and see if it
works the way you intended.
ARIANA MOTT: Yeah.
One of the most important things
is definitely testing VR in VR.
Something that would
work in 2-D does not
work necessarily in VR.
And something that
works on a 6 DoF headset
doesn't necessarily
work on a 3 DoF headset.
So it's really
important to test it out
on the different
types of hardware
that we were working on.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
for those people
watching that weren't able to
attend your session in person,
is there anything
else you can tell them
about getting started
in VR development?
ARIANA MOTT: Yeah.
We have a developer site for
Cardboard and for Daydream,
and those are great
ways to get started.
And we have the SDK, and we have
a bunch of tutorials and apps
that get people started--
either with native code
or with Unity's samples.
And just, the best way to
do it is grab a tutorial app
and just start
moving things around.
And see how things you react
to different things in VR.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much for
hanging out with me today,
and everybody out there, Ariana.
ARIANA MOTT: Thank you
for having me, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thanks for tuning
into one of our
developers show segments
from somewhere in the world.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
check them out right over here.